you guys know what we're making them
that's not wide enough this is one of
the greatest days in the history of our
studio we're making a guillotine of
functioning guillotines jelly bars if
you're watching this Thanks
oh my god Bret you're dead I let
everyone down so sometimes on Fridays a
couple of us like to go down to our
local market peruse through their
awesome craft beer selection from all
over the world it's a classy and tasty
way to wind down after a long week but
there's a problem with doing this on the
regular is that it gets expensive what
if we came up with a contraption that
allowed us to make a little bit of money
each month to pay for these fine beers
you know they say beer doesn't grow on
trees that's how it goes right yeah but
does it grow on guillotines guess what
we're starting a fourth channel oh the
real thing is turning or is this like
hey this is like a lead-in to a funny
segment that we're about to film well
both we're starting a guillotine channel
that's cool like
who wronged you I'm just gonna make a
guillotine channel where we chopped
things with a guillotine there's no
fluff in this channel there's no ifs
ands or buts it's just hundred-percent
condensed guillotine hanta two things
about guillotines guillotine doesn't
really matter how I say it
potato potato nice tat nice tat whatever
number one guillotines are really really
tall number two they're super gruesome
number three it has to fit in the studio
so it does it what do you mean or does
it a death machine I'm not gonna leave
it outside the bed itself
six feet this part twelve feet no and
then it's on a stand
giant sharpened steel blade you go
through the clamp ER and then this part
has to have a lock and and that's where
we're gonna start so I need that I need
like a couple key 3d renderings of this
do you think you can get me like four
designs five designs yeah DT shows up
and got it attracts everyone here is
this how tall it's going to be close put
together you never saw it from that
thing you were led up into it oh you
know what the real ones like this
in the late 70s is when the les
guillotine for death sentences were used
1870s no no here's what I read online
about guillotines being used to commit
legal executions number one the last
public execution took place in France in
1939 and then the last time they used it
for an execution was I think in 1977
yeah we're in France no I swear it's an
American in America yeah we're using
that painting yeah we don't use that
here humane gives it it's way better
than the electric chair though this so
far seems like people are pretty excited
about it we're gonna start with the
wooden structure I'm not gonna get to
the blade in this episode because that
is gonna be a journey unto itself it's
gonna have to be machined needs to be
obviously tested but here we're just
gonna focus on building the guillotine
itself also before I build the blade I
need to know exactly how wide the slide
is first things first we're gonna take
this wood right here we're gonna cut it
and we're gonna put it together in a
different way to make a guillotine
guillotine
this drill why do you need that true I
use this one this one and this one yeah
well if I mess this up I'll probably
never get to make one of these again oh
this is just 3/4 inch plywood nothing
fancy
the pro just obvious to like to make an
interesting things I think six feet long
listen whoever gets on this thing needs
to be comfortable so last thing they're
gonna lay out there's definitely no room
for jack on that door I really wanted
this for right for look at it but you
can't okay well it says it right there
how tall it's supposed to bank 2 and a
half think you're gonna have beats to
toe two and a half days in American Way
[Music]
I don't think is that about the right
hot games deciding this goes I mean your
heads aren't that big we're not gonna
cut someone's head off
look your heads fitting through that
slot perfectly got me the bench too
narrow
I already messed up should I laid on it
before you cut it out talking in a
really bad John Wayne no that's not wide
enough you come and tell me that that's
wide enough for a guillotine and and I
bet you everybody in this studio will
say that that's too narrow fit through
that so your total you'd have two feet
that means that the blade that's too big
yeah the blade would have to be two feet
across
that's so bigger that's so much steel
which is gonna be the biggest piece of
steel in country's ever seen it listen
here Sonny that's the American Way
you got some American on your back yeah
hey I got a question for you
I don't know how wide this guillotine
blade currently my blades only gonna be
11 inches which I think we should make
it way bigger than yeah cuz we want we
want to chop novelty items right 18
inches that's all-purpose sorry John
because it's cut from a two-by-four
piece of wood it's actually not 2x4
really this isn't two by four inches no
it's an inch and a half by three and a
half see why is it not but because it's
machined down isn't that funny
under all my measurements always wrong I
told you this we're not cutting
someone's head out
when did you start working with wood no
I don't know exactly my dad was a
carpenter he would just always be
working on something since I was born he
just was working on things and so I just
started learning stuff from him he'd
make us help him and you like built a
deck him he built two of the houses no
he knew how to build anything so I would
just stand there and like help him and
watch what he was doing I don't know
when I started that as soon as I could
stand and so then I just picked things
up and then I started making things on
my own so that started when I was like
seven eight last year for Christmas I
built rocky a dog house Merry Christmas
buddy
[Music]
[Music]
made me feel like I was about to get my
nose
sawed off mmm hi Sam what are you up to
today I'm up to being a zombie today
because I got the 450 a.m. with my boy
and he usually goes back to sleep around
like seven eight if that happens giving
me an additional hour to sleep but not
today so I slept five hours last night
and for some reason I'm just like oh I'm
the walking dead I'm walking around
pretending like I'm doing things I'm not
doing anything I can't I can't think I
can't focus on something for more than
like ten minutes at the time right now
you know you have you ever been that
tired
yeah or you just look at a computer
screen and you're like I can't I can't
think of a single thing mm-hmm
listen this is corridor digital
everything almost always works
I really don't want to use a different
drill for this
[Applause]
I got you got you hold on got you ready
yep alright okay I know I using the
wrong grip that ways the tools man it's
day two of the guillotine build some
things never change I don't know if you
can hear that but we've got a dreamer up
there and that's a perfect segue for me
to tell you about today's sponsor
Squarespace square that's a triangle
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
that makes it possible for any dreamer
to create a website and to market
themselves and to create a business
online now whether you're just a
musician hacking away at keys or want to
be carpenter trying to make a guillotine
in your loading dock
Squarespace has a platform for you you
can use their beautiful award-winning
designer templates to get started it's
real easy
rich space also has new marketing tools
this year so if you guys want to launch
your new elbow launch of products just
let people know what you're doing they
can help you out with that and stand out
in any inbox of course if you're having
trouble understanding your beautiful
award-winning template you can call
there 24/7 award-winning customer
service they'll help you get started
you think you'll be able to get this
done today god I'm not gonna finish this
today probably because I didn't use
squarespace's you new domain experience
instead I tried to go out and purchase
my own URL from a separate hosting site
rather than just doing it all in one
through Squarespace which you can do I
mean way more time cost me more money
and now I'm not gonna get this down on
time anyway guys it's never been easy
here to start an online store 2019
should be the year to do it go to
Squarespace calm to get started and when
you're ready to launch your site go to
Squarespace calm / corridor crew and get
10% as always off your first purchase
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
well it's important to make pilot holes
because if you don't your wood cracks
how do you make a pilot hole what is a
pilot hole well a pilot hole see is
exactly what it sounds like it's a hole
that pilots in the screw you drill the
pilot hole before you put the screw in
that way when your screw goes into the
wood that you're screwing into it
doesn't crack the wood you see because a
lot of times these screws are so thick
that they'll crack the wood if you don't
use a pilot hole so the hole that you
drill into the wood yes or you put the
screw in
that's exactly right Carmichael come on
man I hate that somebody jammed this in
here not stuck in here forever he's
finding that sound of theirs I think you
would call that jazz
that was pretty smooth I'm not feeling
good about this one there I hit it I
actually did it
did you see how its slid cuz that's cuz
I found the pilot hole why do you use
washers okay you use washes because it
reinforces and strengthens what you're
doing creates more structural integrity
to use a washer because then it ensures
that your heads don't sink below a
certain point you know you look like a
carpenter but you don't show it up sure
don't act like one
let's try to get these distinct what's
up it's just crooked now I need to redo
the bolt I want to do that but when we
get to the actual blade I cannot be that
imprecise what happens appearance
precise with the blade I mean if I'm
imprecise with the blade basically the
blade doesn't have a straight path
meaning that it's interrupted by
friction with the size of the mass you
don't get a clean cut basically you
could blink before you die I like how
you're setting this whole thing up as
like a death machine I mean that's what
yes you're right it is that's not what
we're going to use it so that's the idea
right
maybe that's pacing for Christian be
I'll just keep
that's that yeah I gotta I gotta take
these out because I need to be able to
screw all the way through into just take
these out flip this leg yeah I suppose I
could do that talk me into it kid
your German efficiency is coming through
[Applause]
yeah and because I didn't use a prize
I've made a small crack in the woods I
thought the four by fours could handle
it okay I was wrong okay you need to
practice one thing in your life
what's that take your own advice
well it's important to make pilot holes
because if you don't you're wood cracks
I finally have base frame semi
constructed now my work correctly this
should fit right in these gurus right
here let's find out let's find out so
you made a Wood Cup son you put a keep
your kids mattress on that
look at that Sun those open in the
sturdy what's this
that's a what happens when you not a
union carpenter
[Music]
[Applause]
this needs to connect
Jake's been working on this guillotine
all week I've heard the banging and the
Sun and hammering in the background I'm
gonna build the the mast separately so
we can get it inside the studio here let
me just show you how tall the mass is
watch your toes sides and your heels
fired so you're at the front okay
[Music]
business and these are gonna go here
[Music]
there this gives you a sense of just how
large this is gonna be and how impactful
it's gonna be imagine 18 inch wide piece
of steel falling from that height so we
gonna weigh what like 30 in a way about
30 pounds
ya know that I'm staying out all this is
I don't think it's gonna have a problem
yeah the problem that we're having it's
not done it's not done because I got
more work to do son and and in the
course of all this like I'm trying to
build this like on off days when I got
extra time and stuff running around out
of the studio and filming other videos
and stuff so I'm trying to make time for
this and is to get this far but I got to
move on to some few other things meaning
the next time we come back to this it's
gonna be complete and we're gonna be
building the blade and I know that's
somebody okay you guys were like man I
want to see this guillotine chop some
stuff well just to give you guys a
little taste
[Music]
you guys are interested in following us
on the rest of this journey when we make
the blade and we start actually chopping
stuff with that guillotine consider
subscribing I had this dream about Brett
he was like six stories climbing the
outside of this like bamboo scaffolding
like Brett was chill just chill he's
like don't worry about me son I got it
son in the most brutal gruesome way he
slips falls over backwards starts
hitting this bamboo scaffolding and he
just like belly flops on the ground it's
like a good son don't worry about me sir
I'm good I'm like oh my god Brett you're
dead dude that's exactly what he would
say if he felt like that he'd go oh I'm
good son